please be seated everyone
well everybody it's a pleasure to see
you all how long has it been was it
february 2020
that we're all last here in this chamber
it feels like a long time i've almost
forgotten what you all look like but
it's all coming back fast
yes
right
good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the press and
public i welcome you to this meeting of
the council
i'll go through the fire evacuation
procedures very quickly if the fire
alarm is activated please vacate the
offices fire the stairs either through
the security doors to my right or
opposite the lifts in the foyer please
don't use the lifts please assemble in
hawley square on the green officers will
assist you and advise when it's deemed
safe to return to the chamber
with respect to filming of the meeting i
would advise that if filming takes place
anyone in attendance in the public areas
may have their image captured i
therefore urge anyone filming
proceedings to avoid filming members of
the public particularly if there are
children present
now does anyone intend to film the
meeting this evening
and i don't see
anyone filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered following the exclusion of
the present public from this meeting
with everyone present please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they are not used make or receive
phone calls whilst this meeting is in
progress
well done
so greg moving straight on to agenda
item number one apologies for absence
i've received apologies from councillors
dexter and rogers
and
councillor bayford as well who's under
the weather
um
it was a devil of a job to tell him he
should stay away um he's um
he said it's the first meeting and i've
missed in 30 years
astonishing councillor piper
thank you councillor bertie gregor he's
unable to make it he's unwell
thank you
do i have any other apologies yes chair
where are we
yes apologies from councillor huxley
councillor pat moore councillor
hopkinson
councillor crittenden councillor
duckworth and councillor greene
thank you thank you for that
and i think that probably is everyone
that is not here this evening
thank you
therefore moving on to agenda item two
declarations of interest are there any
declarations of interest counselors
which make this evening
and i don't believe there are any i
certainly don't see any
so therefore straight on to agenda item
three with respect to exclusion of the
present public i call upon the deputy
monitoring officer estelle culligan
thank you very much chair i just wanted
to explain briefly um why uh this report
is proposed to be in restricted session
it's said that it's restricted by
under paragraph one of schedule 12a of
the local government act 1972 which is
in information about any individual
and
as you see in the report it relates to
the appointment of four individuals to
the independent persons panel and there
are details in the report about brief
details about their biographies so it is
appropriate that it is in restricted
session and that's the reason why there
is a proposal for that on the agenda
tonight thanks very much
thank you very much indeed estelle
therefore i move that the public and
press be excluded from the meeting for
agenda item 4 coming up as it contains
exempt information as defined in
paragraph one of part one schedule 12a
of the local government act 1972 as
amended with the vice chair please
second
gen
second
chair
thank you vice chair
gender item for there for the
oh sorry yes thank you for that uh
democratic services do men disagree
thank you
yes thank you
james is on the ball